I was dancing and then white student
proceeded to take me from where I was
and he movements the center of the dance
floor and said dance / dance racism is
alive and well on college campuses
across America this isn't the age of
legal segregation but black students
still don't feel welcome on US campuses
and they're leading a growing protest
campaign in response here are four
issues students want addressed WTFs or
what some people call microaggressions
basically a quick negative comment or
exchange made intentionally or
unintentionally to someone from a
marginalized group I remember taking my
shower caddy into the shower one morning
getting ready for class and someone
looking into my shower caddy and saying
oh that shampoo that's the same shampoo
I used and I said yeah you know what
about it he said well I didn't think
black people used shampoo the name
suggests that these incidents aren't
that big of a deal
taken alone maybe they're not but over
time they create the sense that the
person on the receiving end is different
that's why folks have taken to Twitter
using the hashtag black on campus when
being intelligent makes you not like the
rest of them or when you're the only
black student in class and asked are you
sure you're in the right class and it's
not just students who are speaking out
black professors have also chimed in
with their own experiences black on
campus means that for 16 years students
still seem surprised Stevie because
they've never had a black professor
around 15 percent of u.s. college
students in the country are black but
only 6 percent of college faculty are 79
percent of college faculty are white in
fact there isn't a single state flagship
university where the black faculty
reaches 10 percent and only a handful of
them have more than 5 percent protesters
want that change they want more black
professors and teachers on campuses the
idea is that having a more diverse
faculty will help students fit in it
also helped their demands to be heard
in the last 25 years the number of black
students on US campuses has increased
but dropout rates remain
disproportionately higher for black
students compared to their white
classmates only 21 percent of black
college students graduate in four years
compared to roughly 43% of white
students protestors want more support
services for students including more
mental health workers of color to
provide the help they need to graduate
many universities have a formal system
for reporting racist incidents and hate
crimes but protesters say this isn't
enough I think the main sentiment that
is shared among students black students
across campuses is apathy from
administration a common demand is to
have a chief diversity officer to make
sure there's more diversity training and
recruitment to implement campus policies
and to respond to racial harassment
these students are risking grades
scholarships and some have even faced
death threats fifty years after the
Civil Rights Act when will colleges
create a safe and welcoming environment
for black students